>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> I', Kristi Finefield, I'm a
Reference Librarian in the Prints
and Photographs Division, which essentially
means my job is to connect researchers
with the visual materials in our collections.
And I do that both in the Prints
and Photographs Reading Room,
as well as online in our
Ask a Librarian service.
I also write for the Picture This blog,
and moderate the flicker photo stream
that Prints and Photographs maintains.
I actually remember a lot of my
interactions fondly, usually they --
a lot of them start very
typically, like I think it's going
to be a very straightforward
simple reference question,
and it evolves into something much
more interesting or much more exciting,
or I learn something from the researcher.
I had just a quick example, I had a researcher
who wrote in, I never actually met him
in person, he never actually
made it to the Reading Room,
and yet we had a very engaged
conversation about photo -- about drawings.
He wrote from Canada, and yet he was a student
of the U.S. Civil War, which is interesting.
And he was trying to find the digital versions
of our Alfred Waud documentary drawings
of the Civil War, so these are sketches done
on the battlefield, right
there in the line of fire.
Some of the only, kind of, eyewitness accounts
of the Civil War during battle are
these drawings done by various artists.
So, we have about 1,000 or so of his drawings
digitized, and he couldn't find them.
So, the question was very simple,
"I was trying to find, or I can't --
I know you have them, and I haven't
found the right spot to start searching."
That's an easy question, very
straightforward, I sent him the link,
showed him how to do the searches.
And then he wrote back and
thanked me, and was said oh,
he was seeing drawings he'd never seen
before, you know, he'd only seen ones
that had been published in books, and there's
hundreds more that weren't readily available.
So, I ended up -- and he said he
was going to give a presentation
to his Civil War Round Table group,
and they were going to just love it.
So, I ended up writing back, and telling
him some things that aren't evident
from the digital images, which
brings me to why it's so valuable.
If you can, come to the Prints and Photographs
Reading Room, you get a new perspective
on original materials that you can't
necessarily get as effectively online.
So, I explained to him, make sure
you pay attention to the size
of the drawings, we have the size in the record.
Some of the pieces of paper are this big,
and he's drawn a full battle scene on them.
Paper was precious or scarce, hard to come by,
sometimes we could do drawings on both sides
of the paper, and we scan
both sides and indicate that.
So, he said that added a
lot to his presentation,
but he was so enthusiastic
that it got me enthusiastic.
I looked at the drawings again, you know,
I'd looked at them many times before,
but it gave me new perspective on how
exciting they are to see for the first time.
So, then he wrote back, and told
me all about his talk later so,
it was like we became buddies, or friends
over the material that he was engaged with.
One thing I'd like to tell people about our
collections is, don't stop at one image.
When you find an image you're
interested in, don't let that be the end
of your research, or the
end of your exploration.
Because inevitably that image relates
to something else in our collection,
it's either part of a larger group of photos, if
it's a photo, it's part of a large collection.
It might relate in some way to a different
format we have, and I just think if you stop
at one, then you sell yourself short on
learning the full context of an image,
and that's where the story lies I think.
>> This has been a presentation of The
Library of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.